[Music]
Vampire Diaries fans get ready it's
almost time for legacies but before you
get into the new show there may be some
things that you don't know about the
cast stay tuned to find out who won't be
making the transition from the originals
to legacies are you new around here
don't forget to give this video a big
thumbs up and subscribe to the things
for more great videos like this goodbye
hope now under 10 things you didn't know
about the cast of The CW TV show
legacies body shaming you might think
that famous people are all pretty and
perfect after all a lot of them do make
their careers from being extremely
beautiful and talented but Fame comes
with a dark side you are always in the
public eye and when that happens no one
is safe from judgment not even
celebrities Danielle rose Russell who
will play hope Michaelson and legacies
knows this firsthand you may look at her
and see how beautiful she is but she
actually has been body shamed by fans at
one point the shaming got so intense
that she had to take to her Instagram to
release a statement quote I will rarely
address this but it's extremely
upsetting that people are calling me
unworthy a bad actress or degrading me
because I have curves
end quote she continued with quote my
petite curves make me different from a
lot of actresses out there but I don't
look at them as anything less than
beautiful end quote
when you look at such a gorgeous actress
it's hard to believe that people would
say mean things about her looks but even
the prettiest of people have haters
we're happy that Danielle didn't let the
haters get to her and was able to keep
on shining not a newbie since we're on
the topic of Danielle let's keep going
for a second you may only know Danielle
for her role in the originals which
landed her the job on legacies but
Danielle is no newbie to the acting
scene in fact she was in the movie Aloha
with huge stars like Bradley Cooper Emma
Stone John Krasinski Rachel McAdams in
Alec Baldwin before she broke into the
big scene she was honing her acting
skills by appearing in a number of
commercials and small projects before
she got her big break but before she
even started
acting she actually had a different job
she began modeling at a young age and
that's how she eventually broke into the
acting world it's not much of a surprise
that she is a star her parents were both
stars in their own right as well her
mother was a Rockette and her father was
a singer with genes like that it's
almost as if Danielle had no choice but
to be famous her role in legacies will
be one of her first leading roles after
seeing her in the originals we are super
excited to see more of her and see how
she does with a bigger role Klaus won't
be there for a lot of us Klaus was one
of our favorite of the Vampire Diaries
characters he started out as being a
completely evil character but over time
he evolved and we got to see the motives
behind the things that he did and we
grew to at least be able to stand him he
was one of our favorite characters to
love / hate and that feeling only grew
on the originals but if you are hoping
to see him on legacies then don't hold
your breath Klaus won't be on the show
during the comic-con panel
Joseph Morgan the actor who plays Klaus
accidentally revealed that Klaus won't
be on the show he actually even said
that Klaus probably won't make it past
the end of the originals that might be a
hard pill to swallow but for fans who
really loved Klaus there may be a
glimmer of hope
though Josef did reveal that Klaus
probably won't be making a return he did
say that it all depends on how the
originals ends so if Klaus has a
somewhat happy ending in the originals
there is a chance that we may see more
of him so keep your fingers crossed and
hope for the best for mr. Claus Nina
Dobrev probably won't be back speaking
of old characters there is another
character that probably won't be back
and that's Elena Gilbert
Elena was the main character in the
Vampire Diaries at the beginning of the
series the show centered around her love
triangle with the Salvador boys but
eventually nina dobrev the actress who
plays Elena decided to leave the show
early rumor has it that she left because
she split from one of the other actors
on the show but nothing's been confirmed
anywho it has been revealed that
Legacy's has an open-door policy and
that
anyone from any of the franchise shows
can come back when they want that is
great to hear but given how Nina left
the Vampire Diaries so abruptly we doubt
she'll be coming back to the franchise
anytime soon though Elena may not be
back in person there will be a mention
of her character throughout legacies
Elena will still be living in Mystic
Falls during the timeframe of legacies
and running a medical practice from the
town so we'll still hear a little bit
about her storyline it's sad to think
that we may never see Elena on our
screens again but we are happy that
we'll still see more of the other
characters in Mystic Falls Caroline may
be back there are so many characters
that we fell in love with on the Vampire
Diaries
one of the most lovable characters was
Caroline Forbes
she was the police chief's daughter and
for a while she was one of the most
annoying people on the show but as the
show went on she became a great friend
to Elena and a solid member of the show
Caroline definitely had a winding
journey on the original Vampire Diaries
show she went from being in love with
the town's resident werewolf to having a
love affair with Klaus fans weren't
completely enthralled with her journey
and how she went from cheerleader to
vampire
she went from sweet girl to absolute
warrior so it's only natural that fans
would want to know if Caroline would be
making an appearance on legacies well
Caroline fans the answer is yes
Matt Davis who plays Alaric Saltzman on
the show revealed that Caroline will
definitely be making an appearance oh my
god Rick that would be just amazing
Candace King the actress who portrays
Caroline loves the characters so much so
it would only make sense that she would
have fun playing the role one more time
plus she and Matt are great friends so
she still has that connection to the
show Peyton Alec Smith along with all of
the old favorites there will definitely
be some new faces added to the mix of
people on legacies one of those people
is Peyton Alex Smith Peyton will play
the role of Rafael Rafael is described
as a person who is extremely charismatic
but also dangerous he is a newly turned
werewolf and he comes from a troubled
past
due to his childhood filled with abuse
and anger
still has a loyal heart of gold he tries
his best to do the right thing but is
often sidetracked peyton has been acting
for a while but he's only just recently
begun landing big roles most recently he
was on the bTW series the quad and he
was also in the drama Detroit before he
was an actor he went to Florida A&M
University and graduated with a
bachelor's degree if he looks familiar
to you but you haven't seen the quad
then you may recognize him from his
cameo on the series Luke Cage we love
seeing new faces and we're super excited
to see how peyton does on the show we're
all so excited to see how this new
character fits into the world of
vampires and werewolves Kaylee Bryant
speaking of new faces there are more
that we still need to cover like Kaylee
Bryant well Kaylee isn't completely new
you may remember her from the Vampire
Diaries
she played just set Josie Saltzman Joe
set is one of the larks twin daughters
Josette has a very strange history she
was the daughter of Joe Laughlin and
Alaric but Joe was stabbed while she was
pregnant with the twins while Joe passed
away from this the twins were
transferred into Caroline Forbes womb
see complicated but while you may know a
lot about Josie you probably don't know
much about the actress who plays her
Kaylee first starred in the movie meri
loss of soul an indie film which
premiered in 2014 after that she had a
few appearances on the Disney Channel
series kicking it before she was an
actress she modeled with looks like that
her former career is not surprising at
all she started modeling when she was a
small child and appeared in several
Ralph Lauren campaigns up until she was
10 years old by that time she had
started acting and was well on her way
to stardom she also appeared on the real
O'Neal's Criminal Minds an American
Horror Story and now that she's on
Legacy's the road only looks brighter
Quincy Foust naturally because hope will
be attending a new school there will
need to be lots of new kids on the show
one of those new kids will be mg played
by Quincy Foust mg is a popular kid at
the school he's also known for being
extremely brilliant he's a kid who has
spent his time putting on shows for
everyone else he is well mannered
kind so that he doesn't embarrass his
parents he basically never allows
himself to fully be himself because he
wants to come across as the perfect son
lots of girls are in love with M G but
unfortunately not the one that he wants
and you didn't hear it from us but it's
Lizzy Saltzman M G spends most of his
time yearning for the approval of others
but very rarely can he get it from the
people who he admires most Quincy is
most widely recognized from his role in
the Goldbergs
he played Taz money and was a regular on
the show he then landed a role in the
movie Logan alongside Hugh Jackman which
is no easy feat and before all of that
Quincy was in the television comedy the
kicker that was one of his earliest
acting roles if you haven't seen any of
the things that we've mentioned but
still think that Quincy looks familiar
then you may have seen him in Disney's
KC Undercover he guest-starred on the
show in 2016 or if you're sitting there
thinking that Quincy doesn't look
familiar at all don't worry you'll be
seeing a lot of his face Matt Davis okay
we're done talking about the new faces
on the show let's get back to some of
the old faithful cast members one of
those people is Matt Davis you may know
him better as Alaric Saltzman Alaric was
originally just a supporting character
in The Vampire Diaries but he eventually
became one of the leading characters
originally he was a teacher at Mystic
Falls High School he came to Mystic
Falls to find the vampire who he
believed harmed his wife but eventually
he found out that she in fact left him
on her own accord to become a vampire it
was also revealed that Elena was his
daughter
Alaric's main claim to fame was that he
had the Gilbert ring which allowed him
to return from death unfortunately he
used the ring too much and ended up
developing an alter ego that was quite
dark his dark side hated vampires and
hunted them in legacies he'll be one of
the principal characters on the show the
actor who plays Alaric Matt Davis is a
seasoned actor you may recognize him
from one super popular movie starring
Reese Witherspoon want to make a guess
on what we're talking about Legally
Blonde hello that's right our own
brooding Alaric was actually in Legally
blonde but you never would have guessed
that Matt Donovan is back you may have
gotten wrapped up in Elena's love
affairs with Stefan and Damon but we
can't forget that she had a relationship
before any of that even started and it
was with none other than Matt Donovan
Mystic Falls resident good guy
Matt's character went through a lot his
sister passed away pretty early on in
the series which was pretty traumatic
and then she came back to life and the
whole thing was one big mess even though
Matt was pretty hopelessly tragic we all
still loved him which is why we're so
excited that he's coming back in
legacies in Legacy as mad as a sheriff
the townspeople think that he's a little
crazy because he's always talking about
conspiracy theories and vampires but if
you know anything about the real Mystic
Falls then you know he has a reason to
be concerned
Zach Rorick plays Matt on the show you
may know Zach from Friday Night Lights
he played the character cash he was also
on the soap opera as the world turns so
you might recognize him from that but
you probably didn't know about Zach
though is that he dated one of his
Vampire Diaries co-stars oh you would
like to know who well will tell you none
other than Natalie Kelly that's it for
10 things you didn't know about the cast
of CW TV show legacies were you
surprised by anything on the list let us
know in the comments
[Music]